[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
happy hump day
ours maybe we'll refer to it
[Music]
as Marco got his hands kicked last night
day I don't know
Val dimming's absolutely wanted Little
Marco up and dumped him in the [ __ ]
trash
holy moly
poor poor Marco Rubio he never stood a
chance why did he degree why did he
agree to a debate in the first place I
don't understand why you didn't just
hide like he normally does what's the
difference what is the difference
you could have just hid and not gave us
the clips the great glorious clips of
him losing a debate
he clearly lost
Val demmings
gave no [ __ ] last night
she came to win the election Marco Rubio
came to appear before the Floridians to
make sure that they knew that he was
still alive apparently
and by the time it was done there was a
dead body on stage
oh my God
the one thing I want to talk about in
the in the a block
this morning
is this this notion about the ballot
drop boxes
of course Marco Rubio said Despicable
[ __ ]
and capitulated to the NRA of course he
did he's been doing that
and of course he said Despicable [ __ ]
about women's rights and their their bot
their right to their bodily autonomy of
course he said
despicable [ __ ] amount man and they try
to backtrack a lot of Despicable stuff
even more Despicable stuff that he said
in the past and his voting record which
Val demmings held his feet to the fire
on that last night
but this thing about the ballot drop
boxes the mail-in ballot drop boxes this
is the dumbest [ __ ] argument
I have ever heard and we're gonna see
more of this stupid [ __ ]
as elections and early voting is gearing
up and these mail-in ballots happen
because these these [ __ ] moglodytes
are going to be yelling and screaming
about drop boxes for mail-in ballots
so much so that Marco Rubio said people
are gonna put bombs in them or some [ __ ]
what
there is no one besides Trump supporters
who would even have the notion
to stick a bomb
inside of a mail-in ballot drop box
if there is someone threatening to
commit domestic terrorism
because of a
mail-in ballot drop box
it's a [ __ ] moglodyte
Marco Rubio knows that
I know that you know that
everybody knows that
they called themselves domestic
terrorists
they call themselves that we are all
domestic terrorists at CPAC in Texas
and Marco Rubio is terrified
those
those male and ballot drop boxes are
scary
ooh scary drop boxes
okay folks
you want to know why this is really
[ __ ] dumb other than the fact that if
anyone's gonna [ __ ]
commit domestic terrorism on a mail-in
ballot drop box it's the [ __ ] q and
on conspiracy theorist
hello think McFly Think Jesus Christ
this isn't difficult
it's like CRT in your math okay
when you get a mail-in ballot in Most
states in some States they're called
absentee ballots because you can't
actually get a mail-in value you got to
have an absentee reason it's really
[ __ ] dumb but you got to have a
reason to receive your ballot in your
mailbox
it's a government mailbox
literally the United States Postal
Service is the one in charge of carrying
that mail
that's what makes this [ __ ] scare
tactic against the mail-in ballot drop
boxes so [ __ ] dumb this is why
Republicans are trying to cheat to win
because they're trying to get rid of
mail-in ballot drop boxes secure Drop
Boxes by the way
most of them are bolted to the [ __ ]
ground
they're locked and they have security
cameras on them some form of security on
them like a light or a camera something
now
if the Dropbox is so [ __ ] scary Marco
Rubio
what about all the United States Postal
Service boxes that are sitting all
around town grocery store in front of
the [ __ ] post office
the [ __ ] mailbox is sitting out in
front of your house are bolted to the
side of your door you are some dumb
[ __ ]
how in the actual [ __ ] do you think an
absentee ballot or a mail-in ballot
depending on which [ __ ] State you're
in whether you have a bunch of
Republicans trying to rig up your
elections or not
what in the [ __ ] do you think you put a
goddamn mail-in ballot in
when you request a mail-in bat in some
States they're all [ __ ] mail-in
that's how they do it like they [ __ ]
mail you your ballot
that is how you [ __ ] vote in some
states that have brains
is that complicated
it's actually really secure
believe it or not that's why they I
don't know that's why they mail you
things in the mail
like
official letters certified letters
bills credit card why do you think they
mail those to you in the mail
is because it's [ __ ] secure
you dolts
but when someone receives a mail-in
ballot in their mailbox Margot Rubio
they're unsecured mailbox most people
who have a [ __ ] mailbox at their
house it's not locked
there's no [ __ ] light on it there's
no camera on it okay
they take it in their house they set it
on the kitchen table hopefully if you
got your mailing about you rip that
[ __ ] open on your way into the
house and immediately go to the kitchen
table or the living room wherever you do
your writing and Mark that [ __ ]
ballot as pro-democracy put that some
[ __ ] appropriately back in the envelope
depending on which Republican [ __ ]
State you're in because they get [ __ ]
picky oh my God they're gonna try to
cancel your vote because you you didn't
[ __ ] have it appropriately all the
way down into envelope it was a little
bit up to where
anything they can do to steal your
[ __ ] vote anything
where do you think you go stick this
[ __ ] mail-in ballot Marco Rubio
what do you think you use Trump type
mind control to tell the election office
what your [ __ ] ballot is I mean this
is really [ __ ] dumb people this is
really [ __ ] stupid
and you're gonna hear this nonsense over
and over and over and over again in the
next three weeks
trust me that [ __ ] Marco Rubio tried
it out on stage they're gonna be trying
it out everywhere
because he was desperate
I mean you could tell he was desperate
to get any kind of Zinger in
and the mail went ballot they're scary
and the Dropbox is who they're even
scarier it's this big metal box with
this latch on it that you pull down and
you stick a piece of paper in there in
an envelope and then you throw it in
it's almost like a night drop at a bank
oh oh
Marco there are United States
Postal Service boxes
all over the place that are gonna have
ballots in them and they're unsecured
boxes
holy actual [ __ ] how in the hell do I
have to tell this to this son of a [ __ ]
how do we have to say these things out
loud this is getting [ __ ] ridiculous
really honestly
that manga in this country doesn't even
realize how mail boxes work
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me you people
are willing to believe this little rube
down in Florida
about scaring you over exploding mail-in
ballot drop boxes and you're not aware
that mail-in ballots go in mail boxes
you are some dumb sons of [ __ ] I mean
the queuing on stuff you know the
conspiracy theories the the the [ __ ]
Sovereign citizen the Mike Flynn
right-wing Christianity [ __ ] white
supremacy [ __ ] just that all that Q
Anon nonsense okay right I I get it
you're delusional you're brainwashed I
get it I get it Facebook has done a
[ __ ] number on your dumb ass
but how in the [ __ ]
how in the God damn hell
did you lose track of your rational
thoughts so much that you were
completely unaware how a [ __ ] mailbox
works
you are some stupid bastards I mean
that's really honestly
folks if we don't go and [ __ ] vote
and show these stupid sons of [ __ ]
that that is we are not putting up with
this garbage anymore we're sick and
tired of your stupid [ __ ] lies it's
enough it's enough of the stupid [ __ ]
lies and honestly it's enough of you
dumb [ __ ] pretending to believe
them
it's enough of it it really is stupid
that's like this Kanye West [ __ ]
as if anyone gives a rats [ __ ] ass
what Kanye West has to say about
politics
he's a dumb [ __ ]
stupid son of a [ __ ] doesn't even
realize that there's no such thing as
the Jewish media and he's a media icon
and we're gonna take his word on
politics get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] all the way the [ __ ] out
and white people running around the
country now acting like Kanye West is a
hero because he utters the words Jewish
media
give me a [ __ ] break you people are
[ __ ] pretending you're pretending
that's all this is it's all again I've
said it a million times we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania and real
life and these people are pretending
that this politic [ __ ] is entertainment
they're pretending it's not
entertainment it's real [ __ ] it's real
policy that will affect your dumb ass
Marco Rubio last night got dunked on
stage because he was talking about high
prices and prescription drugs and Val
dimmings just happened to bring up the
fact that Marco Rubio voted against
lowering drug prices when he had the
chance because he's a [ __ ] box just like
any other [ __ ] Republican now because
they have been totally taken over by
trumpism
it's pretty [ __ ] simple
it's the same reason why a media icon
that
Kanye West doesn't have the platform he
has
because he doesn't know anything about
media
he knows a lot about it
he knows a lot about financing projects
how do you think the [ __ ] gets
[ __ ] off the ground and he's talking
about Jewish media and Jewish Banks it's
all pretend all of it
now I believe that the [ __ ] people
cheering Kanye on Jesus Christ he was on
Chris Cuomo on this what does this news
Nation [ __ ] and who the [ __ ] gives a
[ __ ] about what Chris Cuomo says and
really honestly Chris to have rakanye
West on your [ __ ] show on a cell
phone in the back of a car you really
you really God damn no wonder CNN canned
your ass
I don't blame them how in the [ __ ] are
you gonna run a [ __ ] interview with
Kanye West in the back of a car on his
cell phone
on what is supposed to be a credible
interview you are a dumb [ __ ]
Chris Cuomo
dumb [ __ ]
now Chris did a good job at pushing back
on him so what how hard is it to push
back on someone who's saying Jewish
media Jewish media Jewish Jewish Jewish
media how hard is it to push back on
them it's not it's not difficult
it really isn't just like it's not hard
to figure out how [ __ ] mailboxes work
what the [ __ ]
we are not this stupid we aren't this
stupid
they're pretending folks they're [ __ ]
pretending
you cannot convince me no matter how
[ __ ] much of this garbage that these
people say they believe
that they believe it
we've watched time and time again these
Republican politicians stand on stage
during their primary and say the
election was stolen and Biden isn't
President and then when they come out on
stage in front of a general election
audience
and they know they have to appeal to a
broad population not just a bunch of
psychos
that yeah Joe Biden's president but
meaning he won
that's why Marco Rubio is talking about
mail-in ballot drop boxes being blown up
because he can't make a decent [ __ ]
argument about his [ __ ] party right
now
they frankly don't have one
don't believe me look at the race in
Utah
now Mike Lee is likely going to win that
race in Utah because he's just he's a
sitting senator in Utah
but Mike Lee is going on Sean Hannity's
show begging his audience for money
because Mike Lee knows that Evan
McMillan a former Republican a never
Trumper is within Striking Distance
what is crazy about that race if you
look at that race and why the media is
[ __ ] stupid about paying attention to
polls listen to me stop paying attention
to any poll right now stop it
the only reason why you should pay
attention to the poll is if it motivates
you to vote that's it that's the only
reason why I want you to pay attention
to him when you hear a poll if you're
like well that's going to make me vote
listen to it fine whatever but if you're
like what the [ __ ] go and it gets your
mind good just stop stop listening to
polls
but Mike Lee in Utah
is terrified
that Evan McMullen is within Striking
Distance the craziest part about that
entire race is if you remember back in
2016 the Republicans were looking for
anyone anyone they could run as an
independent or anything to try to stop
Donald Trump
and their main goal was to stop him to
to receive Electoral College votes
because they knew that's how he was
going to win they knew he weren't he
wasn't going to win the popular vote
when's the last time you remember a
[ __ ] Republican winning the popular
vote when's the last time
Mike Lee
the sitting United States Senator
in 2016 when the Hollywood Access tape
came out you know the grab them by the
[ __ ] thing
he just he just couldn't he couldn't
vote for Trump just couldn't do it
couldn't do it he voted for Evan
McMillan the guy who's running against
him now
he voted for him publicly said so
and then in 2020 When Donald Trump
didn't get his way
because he's a [ __ ] baby and a loser
you're a [ __ ] loser and you people
are backing a [ __ ] loser
he didn't even he didn't just lose the
Electoral College vote he lost by eight
[ __ ] million eight million this
country dunked his ass in the trash for
and and 81 million people didn't vote
for Biden a hefty majority voted against
Trump against him they voted against him
just like Mike Lee did
in 2016 and the same Mike Lee
trying to help him with the coup
attempted to overthrow our election
as a sitting senator from Utah
who couldn't stomach voting for this guy
back in 2016.
but now that he got a whiff of power
and it kept Mike Lee in power oh boy
well we just might overturn the
government then
it's all pretend it's all pretend back
in 2016 Mike Lee was pretending not to
like Trump
that was pretending they're pretending
Mike Lee is a [ __ ] [ __ ] box
he has no principle none because he's
still in the Republican Party frankly if
you still are willing to put an R next
to your name you have no principles
whatsoever none
none not one [ __ ] principle I don't
give a [ __ ] what book you hold up on
Sunday what prayers you say I don't give
a rat's ass
if you're willing to put an R next to
your name in this country right now you
are a [ __ ] [ __ ] box
and you should be treated that way
that's how we should treat you as a
[ __ ] Nazi because that's what you are
you're running you're running on
replacing replacement Theory
you're running on white Christian
nationalism
America First Nazism
you got Donald Trump the leader of your
[ __ ] party the god the Messiah
of your [ __ ] cult running around
talking about how American Jews better
get their act together or else and then
you got Kanye West running around
talking about the Jewish media and
Jewish Banks and white people are
cheering him on white people who don't
even not even one [ __ ] song
that Kanye's ever done don't know it and
really if they heard it they were like
oh that's rap music
I don't like that I don't like that when
they sing that kind of music they they
they them them them
under percento is what would happen
it's all pretend
all of it they're pretending Blake
Masters is another [ __ ] good example
in the United States Senate who's a
[ __ ] pretending little [ __ ]
you fake ass [ __ ] Blake Masters
you you literally said no exceptions
none he wants to take War rights away
from women he wants them Barefoot in the
kitchen pregnant forced to give birth
even if even if that baby dies inside of
her
and it kills her [ __ ] her I'll get
another one to cook for me Barefoot in
the kitchen if that's the case
it's Blake Masters thought
as soon as he runs a general election
and realizes that overturning Roe v Wade
awaked a sleeping giant in this country
with registration against women which
all Republicans have figured this out
foreign
[Music]
pretending pretending that far oh man
that shows just can't we can't we gotta
pretend that we're not
that fascist
the politicians are pretending
the [ __ ] Trump voters are pretending
and the sad part is the ones with the p
brains the ones who actually believe
this garbage
are being convinced by The Pretenders
again we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life
and there are folks that believe that
wrestling is [ __ ] real
I'm not saying that that people jumping
on people and jumping on tables and
getting hit with chairs and the injuries
aren't real
they're real athletes
the storyline
who wins the match and who doesn't win
that's all fake
it's fake
It's Entertainment
it's a show
and they think that's what politics is
in this country
that is the [ __ ] garbage about the
stupid mail-in ballot drop boxes
how in the [ __ ] don't you know how a
mailbox works
you do know you are aware
you have enough [ __ ] rational thought
that you can put together that a mail-in
ballot or an absentee ballot again
depending on which [ __ ] Republican
State's trying to steal your vote
it comes in the mailbox it goes back in
the mailbox
how the [ __ ] don't you know this
they do know it
they don't they don't care about the
truth I don't know if you notice this
they don't give a [ __ ] about what's true
because they see the truth as their
enemy
it is their enemy
frankly
it is their enemy
that's why Kanye West ruining his entire
career his entire business his entire
[ __ ]
the entire apparatus that he has built
around him is going to come crashing to
the ground and trust me when I say this
he's gonna blame it on them when it
happens
because he's he's a [ __ ] child Kanye
West is a [ __ ] child
just like Trump
he's blaming everything on Mitch he's
gonna blame losing the Senate on Mitch
McConnell
he's already doing it
Donald Trump is gonna blame losing the
senate race in Pennsylvania
in Georgia and Ohio and in Arizona on
Mitch McConnell
Donald Trump hand-picked Arizona Ohio
Pennsylvania and the Georgia candidates
hand-picked those dumb [ __ ]
that's how they [ __ ] won the Primary
in the first place
is him picking them
in the great pretending
voting block going out pretending they
like Trump and this candidate who he
picked
because I can't wait to see who suplexes
who
you can't pretend folks there's no time
for pretending
we're on [ __ ] life support here if
these people can't figure out how a
[ __ ] mailbox works
and it's up to you to say this democracy
so you must engage you must lean in
listen to me when I tell you this if
you've got a mail-in ballot and you
haven't marked that son of a [ __ ]
pro-democracy do it right now turn this
[ __ ] show off and go vote on that
mail-in ballot
and go put it in a Dropbox put it in
your mailbox walk that son of a [ __ ]
into the district where you vote and
hand it to them whatever is the easiest
to get that ballot counted now
it is crucial [ __ ] Marco Rubio and his
stupid [ __ ] cat calling domestic
manga domestic terrorist to blow up
mail-in ballot drop boxes because that's
frankly what I think he was doing
there's threats of it he knows it he
knows who's threatening it and he's cat
calling them to do it
foreign
ers
wanting to commit death domestic
terrorism knows how a mailbox works you
goddamn be better be aware of that
folks
we do not have we are under three weeks
three weeks three weeks from now I'll be
sitting here on this show
either cheering with you in glory
because we buried these [ __ ]
underneath mountains of votes
with early voting mail-in ballots any
legal way we can vote we piled them
under the mountain of votes even though
they tried to keep us from doing it or
or we will be saddened here three weeks
from now
that our democracy is even in more peril
so don't delay
do not relent do not retreat
keep paying attention
it is super important and one way you
can do that is watch the Tony Michaels
podcast every single weekday for two
full hours Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube Twitter twitch
and you can also support us because we
run on your support
we run on it here that's how we do it
here at the Tony Michaels podcast it's
how we do it every single day you can
leave us a tip
a one-time tip or a monthly tip just go
to Tony Michaels dot live Tony Michaels
dot live slash tip
and leave us a tip but everyone has been
the way that we get support to
is these great designs on these t-shirts
and oh my gosh this the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty these hoodies and these zip
up hoodies it's getting cold and people
want this to warm them up I encourage
you to buy a liberty t-shirt but the
hoodie and the zip up Hoodie is gonna
keep you warm while you're waiting in
line to save your democracy so go to
store.dtonymichaels.com store dot the
Tony michaels.com
to check out your Liberty merch today
and I gotta tell you this one flying off
the shelves too Rhonda Santos can go
[ __ ] himself speaking of [ __ ] from
Florida
I got some news for you though see what
I got this morning oh Ron DeSantis can
go [ __ ] himself
um
the coffee taste I I mean this cup makes
that coffee taste so goddamn good so go
check out
store.the tonymichaels.com check out all
of our merch there the Liberty designs
going fast it's going like hotcakes but
also visit Tony Michaels dot live Tony
Michaels dot live slash tip if you want
to leave us a one-time tip or you can
set it up monthly so you can set it and
forget it we appreciate all your support
the biggest support that support we need
the most is for you to watch this show
for you to watch this show so don't
forget to subscribe here on YouTube and
do not miss a single episode as long as
we're not banned
foreign
on Apple Spotify Google all your
favorite directories listen to us there
too and while you're there subscribing
on your favorite directory make sure to
leave us a great review and follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and if
you're on Facebook right now
listen to me if you're on Facebook I've
been putting videos over on my page at
the Tony Michaels don't forget to follow
us on Facebook if you're on the mind
just touch Facebook page because we
broadcast from the Midas touch Facebook
page and my Facebook page
two spots on Facebook where we broadcast
too so do not forget to follow us on
Facebook as well at the Tony Michaels
and really you can go to
thetonymichaels.com and find all the
links there the Tony michaels.com find
all the links to all this stuff the
socials the interwebs if you want to
leave us a tip it's all over there on
the Tony michaels.com everyone stick
around
oh I got some video that I even want to
show you from yesterday we had a long
conversation with Texas Paul and I had a
few videos I didn't get to but we're
also going to watch um Val demmings
absolutely
make Marco Rubio feel about this big
well maybe this big he's kind of he's
kind of is as big when making him make
him feel smaller everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
Rubio
I have some sad news for you just
getting text messages uh Gabe Sanchez
will not be joining us today on the show
he's a little busy today he's got some
other things that he's doing so he won't
be joining us today and I should have
known this he told me this but I forgot
about it
I thought it was tomorrow but it it's
today and it's possibly tomorrow
he's got some stuff going on some good
stuff don't worry it is good stuff but
he won't be joining us today for the
shitless Roundup so make sure to go over
to Twitter
um and give Gabe Sanchez some [ __ ] just
at I am Gabe Sanchez go
go put him in getting his mentions
getting his mentions and tell him hey
look here friend you're supposed to show
up for the shitless Roundup he's
probably listening right now I don't
know I probably is but just go to his
Twitter go to his Twitter and troll him
a little bit for today it's my fault I
forgot he did tell me
I forgot you ever forget I I forgot I
forgot how mailboxes work
[Music]
it's it's I'm not sure how the mail
Works do you stick this do you stick
this envelope in the Box are you sitting
on the ground for the mailman to pick up
oh I'm not sure how mailboxes work
oh man I just I can't get over this
I mean I know that Marco Rubio's in the
pocket of the NRA I am well aware that
Marco Rubio [ __ ] hates women
[ __ ] hates him he could care less if
women have rights to their bodily
autonomy he's not a woman what does he
give a [ __ ]
I mean that's the Republican way it's on
brand
but this mailbox stuff
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
laughs with the mailboxes you're not
sure how they work
foreign
good luck with that Marco Rubio
[Music]
we got a lot of video to get to in the
shitless Roundup today and now that it's
just me
you know we're gonna have a lot of fun
there's gonna be a lot of ranting a lot
of yelling a lot of screaming into the
microphone today
and you know that I that my my
absolute favorite thing to do
is to go through these clips with you
guys so what I'll try to do is I'll try
to keep track of the chant today
um as we're going now like Kim says here
on Facebook Marco is an idiot
well that is if you can get him to
appear in front of a microphone to be an
idiot
whoosh we um Gabe did the thumbnail
today though did you guys see the
thumbnail or Marco the little water
bottle do you remember that do you
remember when he
the guy the guy he got cottonmouth and
he had to have that little sip of water
in his rebuttal
to I anyway State of the Union they were
like oh let's get it's gonna be a
superstar Marco Rubio is gonna be a
superstar
oh how Marco has fallen I mean didn't
fall very far well I mean his heels that
he wears are like six inches so I you
know he fell six inches or so the guy
wears heels to make himself taller
and we're supposed to listen to these
[ __ ]
about masculinity are you [ __ ]
serious
are you kidding me give me a [ __ ]
break
we gotta go to Marco Rubio about
mailboxes and masculinity I don't think
so everyone
what's what served the Tweety tweets and
the trendy Trends let's get to it
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
everyone welcome back to the show I'm
just letting Gabe Sanchez know that hey
you might you may have some people up in
your mentions on Twitter
for not showing up today of course again
it is my fault I forgot that he wasn't
going to be here but still go give him a
little bit of help because the the most
disappointing thing is
is he won't get to watch this video and
he won't get to react to it he says wow
I said uh I told the audience to go
troll you on Twitter
and for not showing up and he said wow
ah what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do I forgot
I forgot
I forgot he wasn't gonna be here but I
know you're upset that Gabe isn't here
today because you definitely wouldn't
want to hear what Gabe has to say about
this Kimberly Guilfoyle clip
did you see this clip of Kimberly
Guilfoyle this morning she's trending
all over Twitter
and the reason why is because
she knows a thing or two about plastic
surgery
apparently
I mean well or obviously
obviously she knows a thing or two about
blind sister look I'm not against anyone
having plastic surgery I probably need a
little bit of it myself
I mean couldn't everyone I guess use a
little bit of plastic surgery depending
on what your objectives are
I don't know you know it's it's a thing
you can
you can make yourself look like anything
you want and really I'm not against it I
don't give a [ __ ] if you want to have
big old lips a little bitty nose
and puffy
cheeks and looks like someone is taking
some bailing twine
and torn back your face fine whatever I
don't give a [ __ ] whatever you want to
do I don't care but it really is rich
it really is rich
for these dumb [ __ ] to watch
and Andrea Mitchell interview which
Andrew Mitchell is a dumb [ __ ] by the
way maybe I'll go to that clip too
Andrea Mitchell is a dumb [ __ ] by the
way I have no idea why why even any any
cable news TV would have her on anywhere
being a host let alone interviewing the
speaker of the house now I am aware that
Andrea Mitchell
and Nancy Pelosi are really good friends
they're really good [ __ ] friends I'm
sure they both been in politics for
[ __ ] gazillions of years Andrea
Mitchell being on not just on the the
end of the media but she's also was
married to Alan Greenspan
she's the NBC senior foreign
correspondent for crying out loud
why I don't know
she clearly has no idea that the
political environment in our country
right now has never been like this in
her lifetime
and an election so important
that when she would have the Speaker of
the House
Nancy Pelosi or whoever it is but Nancy
Pelosi who is probably her [ __ ]
friend they probably eat dinner together
on a regular basis I'm not [ __ ] you
and I ain't dead that's not even a knock
on Nancy Pelosi or Andrea Mitchell
they're allowed to be friends you're
allowed to be friends who you want to be
friends with I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] but when you have
Nancy Pelosi on your show and you're
like hey why isn't Joe Biden codifying
Roe v Wade and Nancy Pelosi has to
politely explain to you how [ __ ] [ __ ]
gets codified in this country
that hey you dummy there's 50 [ __ ]
Republicans not one of them wants to
help women make sure that they have the
right to their bodily autonomy not
[ __ ] one Republican not any of
them
so that's why Joe Biden can't codify Roe
v Wade
he signed executive orders he's he's
even he's even made the Department of
Justice investigate some of these
[ __ ] laws that these states are
trying to pass
to take away your [ __ ] rights
that before Republicans got a hold of it
was your constitutional right
to your body and your choice and your
privacy in your doctor's office if you
have a uterus if you have a weiner ah
you're cool ah you're fine you ain't got
a uterus by God you get privacy
as soon as you have a uterus oh [ __ ]
privacy gone
because they [ __ ] hate women
but listen
men get plastic surgery women get
plastic surgery
and really I'm I'm not against it I'm
not against plastic surgery I'm really
not actually some people I encourage you
to go get it if it makes you feel great
if it makes you the person who you want
to be great fine there's [ __ ]
technology advances out there that you
can do that stuff
foreign you can do it and it doesn't
have to be extensive or it can be really
extensive I mean Kimberly Guilfoyle
knows something about extensive plastic
surgery
plastic surgery can save lives I'm not
[ __ ] you it can save lives some
people have massive accidents
and are traumatized
and they use plastic surgery in a way to
have some some
short of mental health state
that allows them
to still want to live
so I'm not against plastic surgery
but it really is rich
really is where it's like Kimberly
Guilfoyle
like the [ __ ] poster child a plastic
surgery
like literally when she goes out on
stage she does like a pole dance and a
lap dance and it looks like an
advertisement the plastic surgery
100 percent
I'm not against it whatever I mean you
want to act like you're stripping on
stage fine it's really kind of weird at
a political event really kind of weird I
mean really don't do that
but you know I guess we do now now that
everyone's pretending politics is some
kind of inner has in some kind of
entertainment value
and you're gonna get the [ __ ] clown
on stage like Kimberly Guilfoyle
to dance around
and to show off her plastic surgery
whatever
but it really is [ __ ] rich
but she's knocking she can't knock Nancy
Pelosi in this interview with Andrew
Mitchell I mean there's plenty to knock
them about
hell I might just do it now as a liberal
I'll knock them
but the whole Face-Off thing
let me just show you let me just show
you here
this is her interview here
play it here I got a new sound thing and
I'm hoping it's gonna work here
for the um for the sound let's let's try
see if we can get the sound right I mean
you can't eat but it's like the greatest
hits accepting competence and idiocy and
yet we have like little clapping seals
in the media like you said that are
complicit it's like the guy can do no
wrong yet if this was Donald Trump I
mean my God they'd be you know right
Mar-A-Lago again let's bring it back
into office just so we can impeach him
one more time I mean it's out of control
and you know okay
first off you you dumb
stupid [ __ ]
is that Andrea Mitchell was saying [ __ ]
that Joe Biden can't do
like literally Andrew Mitchell
was
capitulating to your side
by saying why hasn't Joe Biden codified
Roe v Wade he's a failure because he
can't
the president United States does not
have the [ __ ] power to codify Roe v
Wade he can write up plenty executive
orders
he can get he can try to make sure the
Department of Justice is doing their job
and making sure that when these states
are breaking Federal statutes when it
comes to women's rights that they
challenge them in court he's doing what
he can do now the question is the
question is well the question that
Andrea Mitchell should have asked is
Speaker the house are you confident
that if Democrats or when Democrats win
more votes in the Senate and keep the
house you can codify Roe v Wade you can
find a carve out
in the senate for the filibuster to
codify Roe v Wade because the president
had said he would sign it
that's the [ __ ] question
that's the real [ __ ] question that
Andrea Mitchell should have asked
but instead Andrew Mitchell capitulated
to the far right wing the Nazis in this
country like Kimberly Yvonne Kimberly
Gilmore was like oh you're in Biden's
pocket Andrea Mitchell what the [ __ ] out
of here with that nonsense not only is
Andrew mendrell not in his pocket she's
a dumb stupid reporter who isn't
adhering to facts they're still in the
Trump Loop no it's sad because this
country deserves so much better and
where is the journalism these days when
you see like Andrea Mitchell fawning
over Pelosi Pelosi lying what's left of
her face off about
there it is there's the Face-Off thing
what's left of her face
oh this is beautiful here's here's a
person who has not much left of her own
face and again I'm not against this
really I mean I it Kimberly honestly my
personal opinion is you were much more
much better looking without the plastic
surgery but you know I I it's not I
don't give a [ __ ] it's not my choice
you're the one who has to look yourself
in the mirror every day you're the one
who has to go out and look the way you
look [ __ ] it's your choice whatever you
want to do it's your Liberty
to look this plastic whatever doesn't
bother me a bit
but for her to say Nancy Pelosi and
really I don't give a [ __ ] about Nancy
Pelosi and for anyone to act like Nancy
Pelosi hasn't had plastic surgery you're
out of your mind too of course she's had
blacks look at it look at it but why why
what the [ __ ] does someone having
plastic surgery have to do with being
the Speaker of the House what does it
have to do with it not a goddamn thing
that's what about Biden's
accomplishments and the legislative
achievements I mean it's a freak Show I
mean Halloween's around the corner but
it's too much it's fun
foreign
the person who dresses up in Halloween
costumes I'm not [ __ ] you she
dresses up in all kinds of Halloween
kinds all kinds of trump ass Halloween
costumes Trump merch Halloween costumes
he's talking about and and it's an
absolute freak Show I told you she goes
out and she does like a stripper dance
like a pole dance type thing like a lap
dance thing every time she gets on stage
she does this I don't know what the [ __ ]
it is it's kind of weird
like she's getting all the [ __ ] meal
Team Six out in the crowd all riled up
shaken her whatever
I know I whatever you want to do but to
to say
the person who yelled on stage in front
of a microphone
their last rally to try to get the
election yelled the Bastion
really
Nancy Pelosi is the freak Show come on
give me a break the Democratic party is
the Halloween come on give me a break
[ __ ] out of here with this nonsense
um apparently Marco Rubio has some new
merch on his website
um the property of damage oh thank you
Paul for the um for the picture everyone
go go follow go follow Paul and he never
disappoints Paul some Rascal on the
internet someone I think Chris Hayes
called him no something Rascal some rats
go on the internet I think it was Chris
Hayes and that's who called him man
thank you Paul for the uh for uh thank
you for showing us the new merch that's
on Marco Rubio's website I'm just gonna
go down my feed today I think that's
what we're gonna do
oh here's a good one
did you guys know that PBS is doing a
documentary on Mike Flynn that [ __ ]
traitor he's trying to he's trying to
Rally up a a white Christian Army
of traitors is what he's trying to do
now now their goal here is past 2022
folks
um that's why it's so incrutially
important that you get out and vote is
because their their aim is past this
election okay it's not it's not for this
election
I mean obviously they have this
delusional idea that they're gonna try
to [ __ ] use the house to make Donald
Trump the president and and they'll try
it
they'll try it trust me they'll [ __ ]
try it
but
um this is this is this aim for Mike
Flynn and this this this uh shark army
of Christians and he's trying to drum up
um is the aim is way past this election
and that's the the most dangerous death
uh I'm Baron here on Twitch says it
right
this is Putin's guy uh absolutely and
we've had uh
Jim Stewardson he did a documentary you
guys probably went and watched that
documentary
um on on the the link and I don't
remember what episode that was
um I have to remember that if we if we
can find that out maybe we'll put it in
the chat or I'll put it in the comments
down below after the show is over
but Jim Stewart's was on and he's done a
documentary about Q Anon and he believes
that Mike Flynn is actually queuing on
now this documentary is actually a
Frontline documentary for PBS let's
listen to the um the the clip here
Georgia's election probe is advancing
with new search warrants Michael Flynn's
whole life is really a story of culture
war from start to finish regardless
they're soulless General Flynn you know
he's a living martyr this idea that this
was spiritual warfare it's not even an
undertone the battle for the soul of
America using the church as a tool in
collaboration with the Associated Press
what are you fighting for plus you've
got
[Music]
now streaming on PBS
so they they've got this on PBS and I
actually suggested um because I'd like
to watch this I said we should stream
this one together
um I don't know I'm thinking about
streaming this maybe we'll just do it on
Twitch alone all those people on Twitch
are like yeah because I don't know
they'll probably copyright me over on
YouTube they may on Twitch too I don't
know but we would we would stop and
commentate on this thing so if you guys
are interested in streaming this thing
together I'd be interested in doing like
a mass watch on this thing and just uh
talk about this maybe we could even get
Jim uh Stewardson
um on to uh to talk about it I don't
know maybe I'll maybe I'll contact Jim
and see if I can see if he's interested
in uh streaming this together
uh Margie says let's do it watch party
I'm willing to do a I'm willing to do a
lot watch party maybe we'll plan that or
something
um put out announcements I'll I'll get a
hold of Jim and see what he thinks and
see if we can work that out see when we
get a few other people uh and a watch
party maybe we'll do it on Twitch or
something as a special for you guys to
go see that I'd really like to watch
this thing
um I think it's I think it's super
important to be quite honest with you
and the reason why again is their aim
Mike Flynn's aim has passed this
election if you listen to the [ __ ] he's
saying I mean yeah they're they're
acting like this election again it's
pretending they're pretending like this
election is important but they really
don't give a [ __ ] about this election
I mean other than the fact if they win
the house they can really stir [ __ ] up
number one they can they can get rid of
the select committee that's their number
one goal because the truth is not on
their side and they're not going to like
the truth I don't know if you'll watch
what happened in court yesterday but
John Durham [ __ ] the bed again
and they're freaking the [ __ ] out about
it
because the truth is that yeah Russia
did have a lot to do with the 2016
election and they were colluding the
Steele dossier
um probably something to it
and we watched it yesterday as the jury
and only took them a [ __ ] hour an
hour
to say yeah um we're not buying the
whole FBI made this up
to stop Trump
now a lot of people are talking about
Durham this morning and by a lot of
people I mean Republicans
everyone knew Durham's little special
prosecutor and investigations into
Russia was a [ __ ] everyone knew it
from the charges he brought everyone
knew that it was a bunch of [ __ ]
now again this morning these Republicans
are blaming Merrick Garland and acting
like America Merrick Garland is the
Attorney General John Durham is a
special prosecutor
assigned by the last attorney general
Bill Barr and the reason why is so that
if Trump lost Durham could continue his
investigation because I don't know
that's how special prosecutors work
the craziest part about this case
because he's 0-2
Durham's done Durham's done and the
narrative that somehow that Trump was
set up by the FBI or some [ __ ] for the
2016 Russia collusion
that that narrative is [ __ ]
ridiculous it's almost it's almost as if
they're pretending like they pretend
they don't know how mailboxes work
the reason why is because they're
blaming mayor Garland what John Durham
is a special prosecutor
okay he was appointed by Bill Barr
so that way he could continue
Prosecuting after the administration had
switched that's that was the whole point
otherwise the doj who just would have
been investigating you stupid [ __ ]
the other thing about it
is John Durham brought these charges to
a federal court
and he personally prosecuted them in the
courtroom
and the jury's like no it was a jury
trial do you guys know what a jury is
hey Republicans do you know what a jury
is Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I don't know what mailboxes are they
don't know what juries are
hmm
who'd you think these are the people you
want in charge
these are the people you want in charge
of [ __ ] people who don't know what the
[ __ ] mailboxes are don't know what
juries are
don't have any idea that John Durham had
nothing to do with Merrick Garland now
Merrick Garland apparently I'm no
Department of Justice second
expert here other than the [ __ ] I try to
go read to keep track of it there's so
much [ __ ] going on
around these Republican criminals here's
the thing
mayor Garland because he's the AG
currently he actually has the ability
now rather he'll exercise this ability
or not is the question again it's a
question
whether he'll exercise this ability or
not John Durham is going to write a
final report now rather Merrick Garland
actually makes that report public or not
we'll see
and rather he decides to review it or
not that's the question
I don't know
I actually think that this Durham stuff
is juicy
what I mean by that is let's talk about
wedges in elections let's talk about
wedges for their lies listen to me
the Trump
[ __ ] internet
in your threads just just go [ __ ]
type in Durham
Trump
in Twitter
and these [ __ ] there's probably
more posts about how in the last week
about how John Durham is gonna bury Joe
Biden they literally Trump the Trump
internet was acting as if these
megalodites these Maga trolls these
Russian Maka trolls out there were
acting like that John Durham's case was
going to be a slam dunk Joe Biden was
gonna pack his [ __ ] as if Joe Biden has
anything to do with the 2016 election
but Joe Biden's gonna pack his [ __ ]
leave the White House and and install
Donald Trump as president I'm not
[ __ ] you
John Durham was going to be their their
hero here it was going to be oh it was
going to be a lesson in the truth and
all this nonsense
and it [ __ ] the bed because they're
[ __ ] Liars
that's why that's why Donald Trump is
going to lose in court over and over and
over and over again and over again it's
just not gonna work
it's not gonna work
because it's [ __ ] lies
and it doesn't work really well in a
courtroom
it doesn't I mean it can
it can work but it's probably not in a
federal courthouse I mean federal court
houses are completely different than
County courthouses
are completely different than City
courthouse's even state court houses
and Durham knew that
again here's Kent says Durham is a setup
or set up for uh prosecutor malpractice
well I mean he's look John Durham is
going to write a book right that's gonna
be his claim to fame to this whole thing
you'll see I'll I'm telling you right
now next year 2023 is the presidential
race heats up he's going to write a book
about how Russia
was well it was all hoax it was all
action hoax and it was Democrats trying
to steal an election and still not he'll
write a whole [ __ ] stupid ass book
about it
and every single one of these migradites
will buy it
and if Trump has any money left he'll
probably write a check for the book
sales like he did Jared kushner's book I
don't know if you heard that apparently
there was over a hundred thousand
dollars come out of Trump's [ __ ] uh
political fund to buy books really seems
really convenient at a time when Jared
Kushner gets a bestseller it really
feels like they use Trump supporters
money
to make Jared Kushner a best-selling
author I'm not [ __ ] you it's what it
seems like to me okay let's let's go on
so I maybe maybe just maybe
we will uh
we will um do a uh a live stream like a
like a watch party of this uh Mike Flynn
PBS documentary
I'm down for that
now this next video I'm about to show
you
I have no idea if this is real or not
I don't know I cannot tell if it's real
or not and frankly I'm not gonna go look
it up
just the mere fact
that this could be real and this is
believable
absolutely tells the entire story about
our current Republican party and their
personality
you see this says Fox Nation here now
let me go back to the to the Tweet here
um I said y'all and laughed Andrew BOCES
says Fox News is doing a mock trial for
Hunter by
you heard that right
I said that this tweet is claiming this
video is claiming and Fox Nation is
doing a mock trial for Hunter Biden if
you're not if you're not listening to
the show on a regular basis and hearing
me say that we are at the intersection
of WrestleMania in real life these
people are pretending
these people are pretending
to even have a mock trial of the hunter
Biden laptop
oh someone on here in YouTube says with
Judge Joe Brown that's right you're
gonna see Judge Joe Brown in the video
here
and I don't I have no idea if this is
real this could possibly be satire but
with these [ __ ] you cannot tell
watch this [ __ ] it's [ __ ] hilarious
Hunter Biden is the most protected
person in the country
money laundering illegal foreign
lobbying
you have the laptop Infamous big guy
email
the son of vice president is doing deals
funded by the Chinese government
there are so many watch this literally
it says the trial of Hunter Biden
like I'm I'm almost sure
I'm almost sure they're aimier
is to get people to believe that Fox
News is the one who's gonna try did you
see that they tried on about they found
him guilty you're gonna see that [ __ ] in
your threads
there they found him guilty guilty it's
charged hitter Biden's guilty you're
gonna see that stupid [ __ ] they're
probably even going to refer to this as
a real thing I saw it on Fox Nation
I put him in court
what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] me they're selling this as the
trial and everybody they want so badly
so badly
for Hunter Biden to be on trial that
they're willing to do a a student
government mock trial
what the [ __ ]
this is some crazy ass [ __ ] right
come on
like this is satire right
this isn't [ __ ] real like this like
they're not serious about having a mock
trial like this is just the dumbest
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah exactly exactly Manu
on YouTube it says this is Idiocracy
of course it is
it's the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard of
ever
it is hilarious though watch this
there are so many adhesive evidence
to me has ignored it because they wanted
Joe Biden elected president
a mock trial for the American people
oh the Patriots
to get them all riled up to go blow up
mail-in ballot boxes
Marco Rubio with your little cat called
to your domestic terrorist out there
give me a break
let's continue with this nonsense
ladies and gentlemen of the jury I am
here to defend Hunter Biden
here we're attempting to influence
policy objection your honor oh God they
even get the objections going
the Joe Biden defense the
now do you think this is like a scripted
thing or you think this is like Improv
I don't know I'm just wondering
I'm just wondering I mean what's funny
is they have Judge Joe Brown in this in
this clip like they show him and
everybody knows that Judge Joe Brown is
a TV a judge like the [ __ ] and
everyone knows that those [ __ ] TV
Court things as entertaining as they are
they're [ __ ] fake
they're [ __ ] fake
it's fake
when they take your case and they put it
on TV whatever they award you it that
the [ __ ] TV show pays that
everyone [ __ ] knows that it doesn't
take more than two minutes to figure
that out let's watch
let's look at photographs this is what I
there it is all right go back there's
jesuo Brown there he is Judge Joe Brown
baby
oh [ __ ]
oh my God
it makes my brain hurt
it makes my [ __ ] brain hurt but it
makes me laugh so hard it really does
makes me [ __ ] laugh this is hilarious
if you're not laughing at this you're
not living
honestly this is so [ __ ] stupid
and this just shows that Deidre says I'm
dead yes
it's
this is it's [ __ ] hilarious
folks they literally they literally know
they literally know
that Hunter Biden is not going on trial
probably not this year probably not next
year probably not ever
and the reason why they know this is
because the same person who said Matt
gatz is not still not being investigated
and no charges will be brought against
him is the same dumb [ __ ]
that said that Hunter Biden is going to
face charges right we heard this a
couple weeks ago 100 miles gonna face
charges oh breaking news Hunter
Mountain's going to jail
okay
then why why are you faking a mock trial
then with Judge Joe Brown the TV judge
I frankly am disappointed that they
couldn't score Judge Judy frankly I mean
Jesus Christ if you're gonna get
if you're gonna get
a TV judge you gotta [ __ ] you gotta
land Judge Judy for this job right am I
wrong
just you I mean I've watched Joe Brown
I've watched Judge Joe Brown it's
entertaining and he's good but he's no
Judge Judy
he's not he's just not
but you know it's just me it's what I
think of these photographs we really
have no way of knowing what was said
between him and these people yeah yeah
you have no way of knowing what was said
between him and these people do you hear
that yeah yeah you don't have any way
that's why you have to do a mock trial
and not a real one people are really
[ __ ] stupid
this is this is the dumbest [ __ ] because
honestly
these morons think we give at two shits
about rather Hunter Biden is charged
with crimes or not that if he committed
them what in the [ __ ] do we give a [ __ ]
what do I care
if Hunter Biden if he committed crimes
rather he's prosecuted what do I give a
[ __ ] why would I care he's not the
president he's not running any part of
the government
Jesus Christ the voicemails that they
have that they've shown us that is proof
that somehow there's this Insidious
[ __ ] conspiracy that Joe Biden's
running the government or some or Hunter
Biden's running the government or some
[ __ ] are the Chinese or somehow
influencing our government is Joe Biden
calling Hunter Biden and telling him how
much he loves him because he thinks his
son is going to die because of his abuse
of drugs and alcohol
that's the big that's the big [ __ ]
proof that they have that China is
somehow controlling our country that
Hunter Biden who can't even [ __ ] who
can't even get his [ __ ] straight because
of his drug and alcohol habit
his dad is calling crying to him on the
phone for help for him to get help
trying to figure out a way to help his
son because he [ __ ] loves the son the
only son that he has left which most
dads would well Democrat dads apparently
Republican dads don't give two [ __ ]
that's their big proof
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
did he commit qurano if you're going to
try my case try not to lose it
at this time the prosecution rests the
trial of Hunter Biden streaming all the
trail of owner Batten streaming all this
week you see that and then down at the
bottom is like I mocked her over the
American people
like the trial of 100 oh my god did you
see their girl they're gonna air the
federal trial Hunter button they already
arrested him he's he's down and get Mo
and they're gonna try him on national TV
on Fox and Fox News is the only one
carrying it
did you hear that the media is not
paying attention to the trial Hunter
button only Fox News
Jesus [ __ ] Christ whoosh
this is great though
I think this is fantastic honestly Fox
News listen Fox News you should do one
on the trial of Obama too
like seriously this should just be a
[ __ ] like a satire series that you
should do if I could Hillary Clinton too
the trial of Hillary Clinton streaming
all this week literally it says
streaming all this week they have this
pre-recorded and they're going to stream
this as if it's like an Alex Jones trial
where he actually got [ __ ] hammered
with almost a billion dollars worth of
[ __ ] defamation payments
you mean that kind of trial all week you
are some dumb bastards
again I I'm not opposed to them doing
one for Hillary Clinton let's do that
let's do one verb
let's do one for for uh Barack Obama too
oh look the porn Bots are here in the
chat I'll block those the porn Bots are
here
I guess they knew that we were talking
about Hunter Biden
I guess so I don't know he's got
apparently he's got a lot of pictures on
that laptop of him having sex with other
with women
and somehow they think that's illegal to
have naked pictures of yourself or other
adults consenting sexual acts
on your laptop is not illegal dummies
it's not did you did you notice that
James Biden who is apparently
um Joe Biden's brother was trending
yesterday I said hey does he own a
[ __ ] laptop
because this is the thing that we could
really grab a hold of
I mean if James Biden owns a laptop that
must be criminal his last name is Biden
and he's got a laptop
whoosh
I think Chuck Grassley was the one who
tweeted about that the hunter Biden
trial streaming all week
oh my God okay
uh let's go to uh some more news about
an actual criminal huh
let's talk about an actual criminal
committing crimes and Bob Woodward
giving the proof six years later
Woodward you are such a dumb bastard
really this is [ __ ] stupid they're
releasing these documents to sell books
and [ __ ] you pieces of [ __ ] garbage I
used to have some goddamn respect for
Bob Woodward for what he did for this
country when Nixon was president
but this [ __ ] [ __ ] where they're
capitalizing on Book Sales because they
hold a piece of information and it's a
bunch of [ __ ] whatever again I guess
it's their choice
maybe we should start doing something
about it but you know what are we gonna
do here is here is a clip from an audio
book
of Woodward taping Trump listen to this
when they're talking about classified
information
I have built a weapons
before we have stuff that you haven't
even seen or heard about we have stuff
that Putin and she have never heard
about before
so it appears that Grandpa Poopypants is
divulging classifying information and I
guess he was trying to show him some
glass Vine information
ah
and Bob Woodward has it on tape
has had it on tape for a while
apparently
I wish I could make this [ __ ] up but you
just can't make this stuff up
when are we going to have the mock trial
of the documents
like in a federal court
when's that when's that going to happen
when are we going to have all those mock
decisions about the special master
and how Trump's losing in every [ __ ]
Court including the fake Supreme one the
mock supreme court on the documents case
when are we going to air that Fox News
instead they are [ __ ] like this
Laura Ingraham
with more Reefer Madness
someone said this morning
um in the comments that anyone who calls
weed pot doesn't know anything and I you
know I'm guilty of this I have told you
on the show I don't know much about
marijuana I don't smoke a lot of
marijuana an illegal for all these years
I just it doesn't give me the great
feeling it just makes me [ __ ] hungry
and then I eat and then I'm not high
anymore
and I'm probably doing it wrong okay I'm
probably [ __ ] doing it completely
wrong and I probably you know haven't
had any of this in these new strains
right
but here's the thing
just like I'm not gonna [ __ ] knock
anybody for getting plastic surgery
including this one I I just I
I I'm Not Gonna Knock anybody for
wanting to smoke some weed or pot as she
puts it
um and Jim board says I call it pot
yeah right do you smoke pot
Suzanne says cannabis everyone's uh
yelling out what they call it
is smoking some weed some cheap the ganj
you know there's a lot of [ __ ] you call
it right
I don't know I I I'm not a marijuana
user yet
I say yet because I don't know
Missouri's supposed to pass it
recreationally it's going to be on the
ballot so I don't know maybe I'll get
into it maybe I'll start the the Edibles
I can't smoke it though see that's the
problem is I I I I quit smoking
cigarettes many years ago
and I discovered that I can't smoke
anything
I went to a wedding a couple years ago I
was in the wedding party and the groom
had a cigar bar at the wedding so you
know like a little table set up with all
the cigars and the Cutters and
and yeah I'll try I'll try a cigar it's
been a while since I smoked a cigar
since before I stopped smoking
cigarettes and I cut the end off of it
proceeded to smoke the cigar and I
enjoyed it way too much
way too much
so I decided not to continue
like yeah this is
this is gonna this is gonna not be good
I'm gonna start buying cigarettes again
everyone's putting their uh here you go
reefer
the devil's lettuce
the wacky weed that's what we just go on
and get the wacky weed
gummies are good John from Facebook says
um let's see when else we
oh Regina's pimping the uh vaping
um vaping it produces no smoke yeah but
see it see smoking isn't about
just rather you get the smoke it's about
you know holding in your hand blowing
the smoke out watching The Smoke Rise I
mean there's something to that
there's something part of psychology
that makes you addicted to that sort of
thing
I'm telling you now let's see
Keith Keith says weed also makes people
horny well you know maybe I should try
it I don't know
why not let's have a party let's smoke
some weed let's get horny yeah you know
see don't threaten me with a good
[ __ ] time wacky tobacci John says
everyone's just throwing in their uh
the words that they use to describe
their weed
um Jazz cigarettes Pro Fence Supply says
420. there's all kind Mary Jane and
Chris is from YouTube
yeah why not
I'm down
if everyone wants maybe that's what
we'll do maybe we can um
we can do the uh
the watch the the watch party on the
Michael Flynn documentary on PBS and
everyone can smoke a little ganj
foreign
the weed the pot as Laura Ingraham puts
it let's listen it's always a cause for
Democrat celebration when more Americans
are doing things like smoking pot
smoking pot
when more Americans are smoking pot what
does she really believe that people
aren't smoking pot because there's laws
this is the same stupid [ __ ] of they
believe that there's gonna be no [ __ ]
medical procedures
because they banned abortion like you're
a dumb son of a [ __ ]
their actual argument all the time with
guns is if you regulate it it doesn't
get rid of them so why don't you have
that argument for anything else
absolutely anything else
even though pot is a [ __ ] plant
abortion is a medical procedure that
saves your life and guns are
manufactured to kill other human beings
that's the difference there dummy don't
you see it no they don't see it because
they must be smoking too much pot the
younger the better pot is also part of
their new normal the younger the better
so is she suggesting that THC
somehow
has ill again the smoking of it I
couldn't smoke it and and it's not that
I can't smoke it's just if I smoked it I
think I would love it too much
because even even when I dream of myself
like when I remember my dreams which
isn't that often I must drink too much
or something
maybe I killed too many brain cells with
alcohol because that's my drug of choice
not pot as Ingram puts it but here's the
thing
when I dream of myself I'm smoking
cigarettes like I'm still a smoker like
it's still embedded deep inside of my
psyche
so I can't smoke it but I I wouldn't be
against eating it
and try and eat it and apparently the
the [ __ ] high you get from eating it
is way different and better apparently I
again I don't know I
just I haven't done it I'm not saying I
wouldn't maybe we should do it on the
show one day I don't know I don't know
you want you want to watch me get high
on the show and just be a lot of
giggling into the microphone probably
as if that's not what happens already
let's listen
that's why they're sponsoring
initiatives to legalize it in five more
States this election cycle which would
bring the total to 24.
so many Americans are so stoned on a
regular basis that maybe they won't even
know anymore care anymore about how okay
okay this is dumb as the [ __ ] mailbox
thing this is as stupid as the [ __ ]
mailbox thing to pretend that that
people being stoned is not exactly the
almost I don't know like people getting
drunk did these [ __ ] not know I
mean she had two of at least sipped on
Judge jeanine's box wine before she went
on a show she's got no alcohol is legal
right
she's got to know that alcohol the drug
alcohol is [ __ ] legal right
this is really [ __ ] dumb this is dumb
as a mailbox thing that's why everyone's
argument about drugs and having it
legalized always goes to you well you
can buy [ __ ] alcohol enough alcohol
to kill yourself in a goddamn gas
station while you're picking up a pack
of Juicy Fruit
the [ __ ] are you talking about
everyone's getting high how many people
are [ __ ] wasted on a daily basis
alcohol kills way more [ __ ]
way more [ __ ]
then weed will ever dream of
I mean if you got weed and alcohol in a
competition weed would lose every time
on the death toll every [ __ ]
dime they would be the loser
it's really [ __ ] dumb
but you know it is lowering your hands
so let's listen to the final couple
seconds here oh bad things have gotten
that's how bad things have gotten
she thinks it's a bad thing that states
are decriminalizing
marijuana
it's reducing deficits it's increasing
budgets for [ __ ] like education
like literally the tax dollars that
they're collecting on the marijuana that
anyone would smoke otherwise
because frankly the recreational
marijuana where it's at and that the
medical thing it's got medical uses and
I and I I absolutely hear you on that
and here's the thing is that you can tax
the ever 11 [ __ ] out of cigarettes you
can tax the ever living [ __ ] out of
alcohol you can tax the [ __ ] at a
recreational marijuana because people
want to use it and they want to use it
legally
it's not hard why do you think everyone
buy are [ __ ] addicted to lotto
tickets people love to gamble and they
love to gamble legally more than
illegally because they want to do these
things without breaking the [ __ ] law
it's kind of complicated it's not rocket
science
[ __ ] boneheads speaking of [ __ ]
boneheads here's one of the whiners
that John Durham
couldn't make sure that Donald Trump was
crowned king or some [ __ ] listen to this
stupid [ __ ] so Durham has been on this
investigation for years and here we are
Owen two with fewer wins than the
Washington generals okay I guess that's
all we need to know for Matt Gantz what
more do you need to know dummy you
[ __ ] five-headed [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
more do you need to know than what you
just said
John Durham is a special [ __ ]
prosecutor who brought this case outside
the Department of Justice into a federal
court brought stupid [ __ ] charges in
a stupid [ __ ] way and lost 2-0 one of
them he tried to case himself
[ __ ] it [ __ ] out of here hey and I'm not
even going to continue because he just
made the case against what he's about to
say because he's about to whine and cry
about how long it took
[ __ ] Eddie or this nonsense
oh let's see you know what here's
another one
this one's even better
having to see the cash Patel is probably
going to go to prison for some of this
[ __ ] for defending Trump if Trump
doesn't get crowned King this
[ __ ] is going to be locked up in
a Cell somewhere let's listen to cash
but tell because I'm sure it's
intelligent stuff but I think what a lot
of Americans are going to uh take from
this is that you know maybe uh it's not
we're fighting anymore and even if we
put the FBI on trial and you can pay a
guy hundreds of thousands of dollars of
government taxpayer money to participate
in the biggest criminal conspiracy in
America and then he can be tried for
lying to the very employer
um that he gave information to and then
walk out of a federal courthouse a free
man it's quite the uh justice charade
but it happens when you enact a two to
your system of justice that Chris Raines
are like our quarterbacking
okay you see what I'm saying you see
what I'm saying how stupid this is
this is even dumber than the mailbox
thing
[ __ ] says he walked out of a
courthouse yeah he walked out of a
courthouse dummy because a jury in less
than the hour in less than an hour is
like yeah you're full of [ __ ]
this guy did not lie to the FBI the
charges that you brought against him and
the case that you had was [ __ ]
the jury did it in an hour in one hour
the jury figured out that this is all
nonsense and then he blames it on
Garland it's a special prosecutor that
bill Barr appointed and the reason why
they appointed him is so that the next
Attorney General could not get rid of
him
this is what they wanted they wanted to
play all this charades and it didn't
work
it didn't work that's why they're doing
the mock trial
a [ __ ] Hunter Biden on Fox News
they're doing the mock trial of Hunter
Biden
because it's all [ __ ] okay here's
what we're gonna do because I gotta get
to these Marco Rubio Glitz because hey
I'm not going to talk more about the
mailbox thing or play the mailbox clip
what I am going to play is Val deming's
absolutely dunking that [ __ ] in
the trash
and giving a master class of how to
handle these [ __ ] weak pieces of [ __ ]
these weak Fashions so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna take a quick break
when we come back we're gonna start
watching the Marco Rubio Val demings
Clips don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show you know you
are the best audience in the world the
absolute best audience every single one
of you stuck around
they tell you they're like don't take
breaks
when you're live
because the audience will leave and you
guys stayed you're right here right here
with us every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and simulcasting from
the minus touch Facebook page and my
Facebook page
and you guys don't go anywhere they're
like why do you do breaks you shouldn't
do that
the audience will leave I'm like no man
they like the brakes because it gives me
a chance to take a breath get a drink of
water
it gives them a chance to watch some
funny ass gate commercials who doesn't
like the game commercials
gives them a chance to take a break
maybe maybe go take a leak get something
to drink I know you guys are out there
pissing while we're doing the show I
know you're watching on your cell phone
there's probably someone right now
They're laughing their ass off because
they're pissing right now why they're
listening to my voice They Don't Want to
Miss a moment not a moment of this show
not a [ __ ] moment now look look Ken
says love this guy love this guy we love
you you are the best audience in the
entire world and I do mean world
and the reason why you are the best
audience in the entire world is because
you guys are all around the world
when you guys come here every day in the
YouTube chat it's not just people here
in the United States they're in Canada
they're in the UK they're in Australia
they're all over the world
is where they're watching from
right here live every [ __ ] day and I
get comments all the time of people who
re-watch because some places in the
world you're asleep right now let alone
going to the bathroom taking a [ __ ]
taking a piss right now they're asleep
but they re-watched the show and they
comment all the time
you are the greatest audience that
anyone can ask for you really are
you really are even the hate Watchers
out there you're the greatest audience
they're starting to do shows about me on
YouTube I ain't [ __ ] you they're
doing shows about me on YouTube
ah I'm not kidding you I guess that's
how popular you're getting here in the
chat
I don't know but we love having you here
every single weekday live with us
chatting because I know there's a lot of
things going on in the chat
you guys are talking to me you're
talking to Gabe you're talking to the
guest like Texas Paul you're commenting
on what we're showing
you're yelling and screaming hey make
this point make this point and I know I
can't watch every single comment and I
can't see every single one and I wish I
could and I wish we could interact with
every single one of them but there's so
many of you
that come here every single day for your
cathartic release
from just the absolute dumb [ __ ] that
is our politics right now in this nation
and I appreciate you being here every
single day
so share it with your friend
even your Trump relative you know your
Uncle Earl he's always like Adam a
mail-in ballot boxes people gonna blow
them up
and did you see the trial of Hunter
Biden's on Fox news but no one else is
carrying it okay Uncle oral great story
even him show it to him I don't give a
[ __ ] invite them all here invite them
all
and did you know we're we're really
close today
to 11
000 subscribers I don't know did we hit
it yet let's see let's check here
[Music]
computers running slow yes we did we we
broke 11 000 subscribers while we're on
air we did ten thousand and it was a
couple weeks ago
we're at 11 now
we're at 11 now so if you're on another
platform
other than YouTube and if you're on
YouTube right now and you haven't
subscribed what the [ __ ] wrong with
you
what's wrong with you it's so easy you
just hit the [ __ ] button and then you
want to hit the Bell notification to
make sure you get the notification of
the show every day because sometimes I'm
a little late
meaning it's a little late putting it up
I try to get it up you know 15 20
minutes before but sometimes we're
really yeah we're sliding into that to
the base there
to make a home run well we're here every
single weekday has there been a weekday
yet that you haven't seen me here even
when I lost my voice I was here Live on
YouTube for two full hours I sounded
like Alex Jones and Batman [ __ ] and
had a baby
but I was here
and you're here and I appreciate every
single one of you being here on YouTube
Twitter and twitch
and then Facebook
either with your on minus touch Facebook
page all right you're on our Facebook
page but if you're right now if you're
not on YouTube do me a favor go over to
YouTube right now click the button if
you're on YouTube click that [ __ ]
subscribe button it ain't that hard and
really if you're on Facebook as well do
me a huge favor and go follow us on
Facebook
I didn't know people were following me
on Facebook for a long time
I didn't know that and then I went over
and checked it one day I'm like whoa
there's people messaging me and liking
the page and so I started broadcasting
the show and then I started like posting
memes and other videos over there and
more and more people followed and
everyone's engaging there as long as you
engage on a social media platform I will
try to do that and we have this thing
called Discord I don't know if any of
you know what Discord is out there
um I don't I don't know much about it
I'm not very good at Discord I'll have
to admit
I just don't know but we have a Discord
it's a Discord server apparently what
it's called so anyone out there want to
go to Discord and follow on Discord
they're trying to put a a group together
on Discord to figure out what we can do
over on Discord and our channel on
Discord just go type the Tony Michaels
podcast and you'll find it there on
Discord you can also go to
tonymichaels.live and you'll find the
link to the Discord you can go to the
Tony michaels.com and you can find the
link to the Discord
uh also why you're there at the Tony
michaels.com you got to check this out
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty we have them
hoodies
we have zip up hoodies we now have
sweatshirts if you're gonna get cold
listen if you have to stand in line to
vote it may be cold
it may be raining so you might want a
hood
so go over and check out
store.thetonymichaels.com or you can go
to thetonymichaels.com and the store
link is there go to
store.d20michaels.com find your Liberty
hoodies sweaters
and zip up hoodies we also I put long
sleeve shirts that was another thing
people were we have the uh the t-shirts
but there was a few people who wanted
them in long sleeve T-shirts so we put
the long sleeve T-shirts up there the
other day
your wish is my command the best
audience in the entire world and I'm not
kidding the best audience here at the
Tony Michaels podcast Bar None you guys
get it
you guys get it you understand what the
hell is going on
you know what is at stake
I believe that everyone who comes here
has interest in democracy even the hate
Watchers
even if it's like all the way back in
their brain
and it's just whispering to him
democracy democracy good democracy good
you fool just like this fool here Marco
Rubio
did you watch this I didn't watch the
whole thing I'll admit I didn't watch
the whole debate didn't need do
I didn't need to
I didn't
I didn't need to watch this debate to
know that Val demmings absolutely bent
Marco Rubio over her knee and spanked
his ass
we've come a long way I want to say
anyway I do want to say this
because I think this debate shows that
we have come a long way
from this narrative
that black women
can't get angry
what the [ __ ] listen
there is no group of of people in this
country
than women
who can get [ __ ] done and the reason why
because they have to work twice as hard
as you men they have to work twice as
hard as you
to get where they're at like literally
they they have to be smarter faster
better
they have to they have to actually get
[ __ ] done they can't just pretend
and in that group of women black women
have to work just as hard in that group
as women does in the entire group
and really honestly if we could just get
more women like Val demmings
in charge
of fixing what men have broken
whatever it is whatever you want to say
Health Care education law enforcement
you name it you name the [ __ ] topic
that policy needs to be fixed
reform needs to be done we need more
women like valve dammings in charge of
that policy
she gets it and the reason why she gets
it is not only is she [ __ ] sharper
than attack she has the experience of
knowing how to get [ __ ] done
she's a black woman in America okay that
experience alone
qualifies her of doer of [ __ ] and things
getting done okay like that alone her
experience alone
gives her that Authority
white men don't they don't get [ __ ] done
and they're [ __ ] losers
because they don't have to do anything
to get [ __ ]
trust me I is one I know this I've
experienced this
nonsense
the inequality inequity
but Val dimmings she has the experience
and she showed it last night on stage
when she absolutely dunks
Marco Rubio in the [ __ ] trash
this is a particular moment
where she uses her shiv and she really
sticks it in Marco Rubio here
I mean just berries the blade deep
inside Margot Rubio and then starts
twisting it around like she hasn't
stopped there she starts [ __ ]
twisting it watch I know the senator
look and I'm really disappointed in you
a Marco Rubio because I don't I think
there was a time when you did not lie in
order to win
I think she's giving him a lot of credit
there but that might be there might be
some truth to that there might be some
truth to that but that is that is a
heavy knife politically to stick into
your opponent right on stage and looked
him dead in the [ __ ] eyes and say
that [ __ ]
watch how she twists that bleed
all the way all the way
I don't know what happened to you you
know that
my first turn in the United States house
I passed legislation to help law enforce
I don't know what happened to you and of
course this is all Margot Rubio's
attempt in this clip is to question her
Authority and her experience with law
enforcement which she was she was not
only was she a [ __ ] cop she was a
police chief
okay she actually does have the
experience in law enforcement now rather
you like that or not you know you can
question that
but she does have the experience that
Marco Rubio does not so it's a little
Rich for him to be questioning anything
about law enforcement to Bow demings and
she let him have it uh here's another
clip of her letting him have it uh when
it comes to Marco Rubio capitulating to
the NRA and gun manufacturers because
he's in their pocket
well they're in his pocket I should say
why do you think Marco Rubio didn't show
up for anything
you don't see Marco doing anything
and the reason why is because he even
capitulated after the the Parkland
shooting at Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School
he even capitulated to them then you
remember he was standing on stage and
they [ __ ] went after him
because he's he's just an NRA shrill for
the gun manufacturers watch this as
[ __ ] Val demmings
again leaves welps on his naked bare ass
the majority of people in our nation
want us to do just that how long will
you watch people being gunned down in
first grade fourth grade high school
college Church synagogue or grocery
store a movie theater a mall and a
nightclub
Congressman do nothing that is time I
want a majority of people in our nation
whoosh that's the clip that's it
remember what I said earlier about this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] nonsense about
angry black women
we're starting to move past that folks
we're starting to move past that because
people were like God damn yeah [ __ ]
get him get his ass
we're starting we're and now we're not
there all the way we're not there all
the way but let me tell you something I
believe I believe that the polls are
wrong in Florida don't believe that [ __ ]
just get out to the [ __ ] polls and
vote for bound demmings
crawl over [ __ ] shards of glass and
hot coals if you have to
uh Susan says she's a badass she's
goddamn right she's a badass she has to
be like I said earlier she's a woman
and on top of that she's a black woman
and in law enforcement
a woman in law enforcement and a black
woman in law enforcement and that
and she's had a success in Democratic
politics
pro-democracy politics
she was high up on the list for vice
president Keith says president but she
was on the list I mean really honestly
it might have been a flip of the coin
for Biden and his team to pick between
Val demmings
and Kamala Harris because Val demmings
is completely capable not of just being
the vice president but Keith's right
completely capable
of being the president
so
um we're making strides in this country
we're not there yet that's why you got
to go vote that's why it's super
important for you to put valve demmings
in a situation where this country can
see
a policy being set by a very strong
black woman
how those policies can progress forward
when you elect people like this
I am very I am very confident the valve
dimmings will not disappoint and I don't
say that kind of [ __ ] here on the show
you notice I don't ever [ __ ] shrill
for any candidate really
I do that on purpose
I mean there's a lot of [ __ ] boxes in
this country
a lot some are [ __ ] Democrats I never
shrived for for Andrew Cuomo
I mean yeah was he doing a great job
with the pandemic I don't know
there were questions on that I never
shield for that [ __ ] piece of trash
I don't chill for him here
because they have to prove it to us
that's democracy [ __ ] they
gotta prove it to us and the way that we
give them the opportunity to prove it is
to put them in charge of something Marco
Rubio has proved to us that he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
about Americans let alone for Floridians
why in the [ __ ] would anyone put Margot
Rubio in charge of anything he has
proven time and time again that he does
not give two shits
about his constituents not a [ __ ] to
give to his constituents Now's the Time
to give the opportunity to the
pro-democracy candidate
and let her prove what the [ __ ] she can
do because I'm highly confident that Val
demmings is gonna get [ __ ] done that's
just how it's gonna be
just like she got [ __ ] done on stage
it's very easy it's very simple
you don't have to make too many
arguments to get there
snap thing what you have to do okay
what's she speaking of Cuomo
I gotta show this I don't want to
uh the internet is forcing me
this is Chris Cuomo his dumbass
now you see someone in the in the car
next to him it looks like he's playing a
video
but this is an actual interview
that Chris Cuomo did on I think it's
called Nation news or news Nation [ __ ]
some kind of app that Chris Coleman was
on now and really honestly the app the
people who talk about it and I was
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] news
nation is it's a bunch of [ __ ]
capitulators do the right they're like
oh we're not biased news agency we both
sides everything it's a bull sizing TV
News Network so it might as well be a
Trader TV News Network for that matter
because they both sides I mean it's not
it's it's it's overtly both sides they
literally do both side [ __ ]
which I want to get to the both sides in
the media here in a second when people
think liberal media and they're not
they're both sides liberal they're in
both sides media not liberal media
here's quish Chris Cuomo and I'm not
going to play a lot of this stupid [ __ ]
because it's Kanye West but literally he
has a [ __ ] interview with Kanye West
here right and you can see that Kanye
West is talking in the car
now he's not I don't think he's driving
I think he's writing I don't know I
think he's riding in the car but you
can't it's on a cell phone what the [ __ ]
is this
[ __ ] is happening let's listen to a bit
of it understand but the thing is
the Jewish people that I'm talking about
don't have to understand and that is
that privilege that I'm not gonna allow
when I wore the White lives matter
t-shirt okay that's enough see yeah yeah
I don't have to get they don't have to
get too far now Chris Cuomo does a good
job of pushing back on Kanye here so it
does have some value and what I mean by
that is is Kanye thinks he's gonna go on
these news outlets and he's gonna yell
and scream this [ __ ] without any [ __ ]
pushback that's what needs to happen
this guy the country needs to show and
the world needs to show that there's
pushback on this [ __ ] that
there's pushback on the stupid
anti-semitic language
this call to violence for Jews and
that's what it is
that's what it is and and really Kanye
thinks he can go around saying the word
Jew and Jewish media and and Jews like
well Jews ain't isn't a racist word no
Jews isn't a racist word just like
Mexican isn't a racist word it's the
context in which you use it and you're
saying that that Jews have some kind of
conspiracy where they're trying to
control the country with the media it's
really [ __ ] Nazi it's really not and
it really shows through where this
country's at and again I told you the
other day the most dangerous thing is
the former president mirroring this
language this crazy idea that Jews are
controlling stuff
as if they're having [ __ ] meetings
and controlling things
whoosh really [ __ ]
dangerous times that we live in here
okay uh let me go to the um
I want to show you this uh someone sent
me this tweet
maybe we'll end on this uh you guys know
what uh Young Turk says right The Young
Turks t-y-t
these [ __ ] stupid Bastards of it and
I've railed on them before right
I have railed on them before their
founder here anybody can find it
there we go anger he used to be on MSNBC
right
now he's he's the guy who runs the whole
operation over there
at The Young Turks this is what they're
saying over there don't go watch this
garbage okay
listen do not go watch this garbage
it's a bunch of [ __ ] and yes he is
Catherine says he's a [ __ ] he is a
[ __ ]
listeners it looks like we're going to
lose the midterms [ __ ] says who
says who says you
people will look back at Democrats
inability to pass voting rights
legislation as the moment we lost
everything you are a stupid [ __ ]
lying bastard
you are a lying [ __ ] the Democrats did
not pass voting rights legislation
there wasn't one Republican who was
willing to pass vote not one
not [ __ ] one there were plenty of
Democrats willing to do it
stunning
third is that Republicans that are in
charge of anything that's where all our
failures come from in this country
is because they don't give a [ __ ] about
Americans just like you don't you don't
give a [ __ ]
and everyone in DC yawned because
they're using used to excusing
democratic failures this is so stupid
this is so stupid
so basically what he's saying
is that he's calling on his supporters
really is what he's doing here he's
calling on his supporters and his
followers and Their audience
to not go vote
because it's good for him when
Republicans are in charge
listen folks nothing would be better for
this show and its ratings for
Republicans to be in charge and the
reason why is because every single
[ __ ] day I'd have something to yell
and scream about
every [ __ ] day if they were in
charge
but I don't give a [ __ ] I don't care I
don't care about rather they're in power
so I get money I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't want them in power because I don't
want them [ __ ]
chopping up your goddamn Liberty it's
ridiculous if they're willing to chop up
your Liberty they're gonna come chop up
mine
and I think Liberty is worth [ __ ]
protecting I don't give a [ __ ] who you
are that's why I don't give a [ __ ] about
what plastic surgery you get Kimberly I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't care if you
get it Andrea Mitchell gets it Nancy
Pelosi whoever the [ __ ] gets plastic sir
I don't even care if Joe Biden Donald
Trump I don't even give a [ __ ] have
plastic surgery Heaven Donald Trump
modifies His Image and his look and his
physical appearance from head to toe
and really honestly it's laughable it's
funny because they think he's masculine
that's hilarious it's great to mock it's
fun to make fun of
but at the end of the day what do I give
a [ __ ] what does that matter what
matters is he's going to take away
people's Liberty he is chomping at the
bit
to cast American Jews out to Israel he
said it
he said it and for tyt
to be broadcasting nonsense like it's
Democrats [ __ ] fault that nothing
gets done in the Senate you are pieces
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're lying about how our democracy
Works you're lying about how our [ __ ]
government works you're lying about how
our elections work you're a [ __ ] liar
and you're trying to capitalize on the
[ __ ] lines just like the right-wing
media and you're no better than they are
because frankly they want
authoritarianism that's what they want
and I don't give a [ __ ] I've had people
I've had people on the show that's been
on tyd
because at
um Jason points out here a rebel HQ is
the only appealing thing I I I've had
I've had and I I follow people who do
the real Rebel HQ the rebel headquarters
for tyt they do different videos but
when they broadcast their newscast they
100 percent are saying oh it's all
Democrats fault all this Democrats fault
because we want our authoritarian Bernie
Sanders to be in charge that's literally
that's literally the entire thing they
love Nina Turner which Nina Turner is a
[ __ ] bonehead she's another one of
these [ __ ] boneheads who blames her
own party
when she can't even win a [ __ ]
election because she's such a [ __ ]
bonehead that's right I said it Nina
Turner is a [ __ ] bonehead
so you can keep listening to the both
side [ __ ]
but let me tell you something this the
self-defeatism is the reason why
Democrats don't win elections and the
reason why Democrats have failures it
ain't failures in the Senate
it's failures out in elections there's
two things folks there's two things
there's government which is policy
which is what these bastards yell and
scream about all the line items that
they want and all the [ __ ] that they
want to get done and Democrats aren't
doing or whatever they want to [ __ ]
about
do you hear me bitching about
demographic but getting policy no
because Democrats can't get policy
when they don't have a carve out or they
have the [ __ ] filibuster because
there's 50 Republicans because they've
rigged elections in this country
that's not a democratic failure
that's not a pro-democracy failure
it's not
there is not two sides in this country
that is why we
as a whole feel like that our country is
divided it's not we're not divided 50
50. that's not a thing we just don't
have two sides of democracy right now
we don't have two sides of democracy we
got one [ __ ] big tent [ __ ]
group of people who are interested in
having a democracy
and they're represented right now by
only one [ __ ] party and we are a
two-party system that is what we are I
don't give a [ __ ] how many [ __ ] third
parties you want and how we can change
it you are a stupid bastard you are a
dumb [ __ ] stop talking about
third parties and how you're gonna
change it it's not gonna happen it won't
happen you are you are not understanding
how our government works if you think
we're going to be Beyond a two-party
system you just don't get it we are not
a parliamentary system it's not a thing
that is not we are not that sort of
democracy we are a two-party system here
and if you want I and I know this is
what tyt wants and their listeners want
they want to smash up our democracy so
they can create the Democracy that they
want well let me tell you something when
you smash a bar democracy when you smash
it up with a hammer guess who's going to
take it over
it ain't gonna be Bernie Sanders
nope it's gonna be the [ __ ] fascist
they're ready they're ready
for both sidesers
who think they're pro-democracy
who are ready to swoop in and take away
your [ __ ] country
take away your Liberty
and anyone fighting against it I don't
give a [ __ ] if you say you're on this
side or that side but if you're both
sides and [ __ ] both sides are the same
oh it's all the same it's all
politicians are the same all policies
the same they're gonna screw you blah
blah blah capitalism capitalism they're
going to screw you we want socialism
then you're not aware of how our
government works and how our country
Works you're just as dumb as the
moglodytes
to be quite honest
and I don't give a [ __ ] I'll say it I'll
say it out loud
you are not an ally for democracy if you
are promoting smashing our democracy
you're not
and I'm not I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
not say it I don't give a [ __ ] the
[ __ ] guy doesn't care
what you think about what he says
how have you figured that out yet
but we should not tolerate this [ __ ]
this both sizing [ __ ] we should band
together
you folks out there that want socialism
fine cool band with us you're definitely
not gonna get it with the [ __ ] right
wing
if you think you're gonna get it with
these bunch of moglodytes taken over
Blake Masters Kerry Lake [ __ ]
Herschel Walker Dr Oz JD Vance who
called America Trump America's Hitler
and now he's [ __ ] sucking at the teat
of trump
you want Ron DeSantis Greg Abbott you
want these [ __ ] in charges [ __ ]
fine great then you're on their side if
that's how you want to both sides it you
are on their side
to kill democracy
so pluck your head out of your ass
and realize that we've only got under
three weeks
to make sure that we
foreign
side's argument meaning you are on the
side of that part of democracy and I'm
on the side of this part of democracy
but right now we do not have two parties
that are interested in democracy only
one only one
and it is up to you to make sure that
that party has the reins of our
democracy or the other one will destroy
it because that's what they want they're
telling you out loud that's what they
want to do we're going to shut down
government we're going to make sure
we're going to destroy the Department of
Education to span the FBI get rid of the
IRS we're going to get rid of the entire
[ __ ] government that's what they're
saying to you you dummies they tried to
overthrow our election
it was a coup attempt
there's not two sides
Traders is not a side
Traders is not a side
that's not a side of our democracy it's
not never was never [ __ ] will be and
I'll keep yelling and screaming it
because I want you I want you to get
engaged and go vote even if you're a tyt
listener and you're like Tony you
bastard you son of a [ __ ] how dare you
see
that [ __ ] about tyt
good [ __ ] go vote then fine
prove me wrong go vote for a republican
if you want if you want to both sides it
go vote for them yeah sure why why not
why not have Republicans in power
Democrats or such failures tyt viewers I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't care I don't
give a [ __ ] what you think come here and
I'll tell you the [ __ ] truth I'm not
gonna feed you up with a bunch of lies
about how our government and our system
doesn't work
I'm not gonna do it
I'm not I'm gonna tell you the straight
truth real raw and No Nonsense
so stay tuned every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch simulcasting from Facebook on the
Midas touch page and on our own page so
don't forget to subscribe right here to
YouTube do not miss a single [ __ ]
episode every single weekday Monday
through Friday on YouTube also follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod tomorrow
will be the bone end of the week poll
you can vote on YouTube and Twitter also
download every single episode please go
download every single episode while
you're there leave a review while you're
subscribing to your favorite directory
it is super important it helps us it
helps us and you are the best audience
in the world speaking of the best
audience in the world there's a huge
audience on Facebook and if you're on
Facebook go follow me at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook you can also find
me on Twitch make sure if you haven't
download twitch Go download this app
because we might do that watch party of
the PBS Mike Flynn documentary we might
all do it together and you guys can eat
gummies and smoke pot you can smoke pot
while we watch the Mike Flynn
documentary everyone
same time the same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn head ass Beacon